this false hurricane damage is severe
what should the federal government do
this massive rebuilding effort will end
up being one of the biggest ever will be
seeking resources from the Congress to
make sure the disaster relief is
available politicians from the areas
that were hit always say give us lots of
money we do need and will need federal
resources Texas congresswoman Sheila
Jackson Lee wants about 150 billion
dollars just for Texas so far Congress
has agreed to a portion of that of
course only the federal government can
send in the military and other first
responders after
13,000 National Guard soldiers helped
rescue and evacuate people this is the
kind of emergency response we expect
from the federal government but
rebuilding afterward why is that the
federal government's responsibility
we're gonna have to restore a lot of
housing our infrastructure has to be
restored yes but why is that a federal
job Washington has no money of its own
anything it spends is taken from states
and local governments from people who
would probably have been smarter about
spending it locally the idea that it's
always the federal government's
responsibility is new until recently
businesses and charities handled most
disaster response
in 1906 the massive San Francisco
earthquake and fire that followed
destroyed 80% of San Francisco
despite this vast amount of destruction
the city was rebuilt quickly the
population recovered the pre quake
levels within just three years this
happened because rebuilding was done by
residents charities and businesses not
by a bureaucratic government the
disaster even created some opportunities
all San Francisco's banks were destroyed
but one banking entrepreneur reopened
quickly giving loans to all sorts of
people who needed help his bank grew to
be the Bank of America
seven years later the Midwest was hit
with a huge storm now called a great
Easter flood 11 states flood rising
water and tornadoes killed 600 people
the federal government did very little
but businesses stepped in the National
Cash Register company built 300 boats to
rescue flood victims and then provided
meals and shelter for thousands of
people the role of businesses after
disaster is seldom appreciated yes they
want to make a profit but they also want
to help neighbors and they want a good
reputation after recent hurricanes
big-box stores like Home Depot and
Walmart were quick to bring in fresh
water batteries and food in Puerto Rico
coca-cola donated a million dollars
PepsiCo 2-million Elon Musk offers to
rebuild Puerto Rico's electricity grid
researchers found that after Hurricane
Katrina businesses and charities
provided much more help than FEMA did a
few years ago Oklahoma took a big hit
for three days tornadoes tore through
the state FEMA spent lots of money to
help rebuild but even nbc's anchors
noticed the private charities that a
better job if you're waiting for the
government you're gonna be in for an
awful long way the baptist men they're
gonna get Tonya Morrow the Baptist men
got bulldozers and cleared tornado
debris from more than a thousand homes
they brought in bobcats and bulldozers
and chainsaws and they just went to work
within days the Baptist gave them a new
home it was a mess out here and they
cleaned it up and they've done that for
our whole neighborhood all of a sudden
we hear hammering and Maddie looks back
and she grabs my shoulder and look up
and they're already on our roof he has
people driving through handing you meals
people I didn't know would just walk up
and give us money it's just overwhelming
to me that we were that taken care of
for 200 years when disasters hits
neighbors took care of neighbors but now
we hear a big storm requires
big government I say the head of the
Baptist charity has it right I don't
think there's any kind of disaster that
can take place that the nonprofit and
faith-based groups cannot take care of
you